enfin sondage ipsos révèle que 63 % des
français préféreraient être incinérés
plutôt qu enterrés ils n'étaient que 20
% en 1979
en 40 ans l'idée de la crémation a donc
fait son chemin dans la tête des
français
mais si la technique funéraire séduit
aujourd'hui elle aura mis quelques
décennies à s'imposer dans les moeurs
bien qu'elle soit autorisée en france
depuis 1887
historiquement je crois que c'est
surtout une perception de la
résurrection qui était un peu selon la
science du temps à compatibles avec
cette idée de disperser des cendres d'un
corps humain en le brûlant
et ce n'est qu'à partir de 1963 que
l'église tolérera enfants d'incinération
décor les funérailles chrétiennes nous
ont autorisés pour ceux qui demandent
l'incinération à condition que leur un
geste ne soit pas interprété comme un
refus de la foi chrétienne
mais cette décision de l'église ne
suffira pas à convaincre les français en
1980 les incinérations ne représentait
que 1 % des décès contre 36 %
aujourd'hui
cette courbe illustre le changement de
moeurs progressif auquel ont contribué
les nombreuses associations en faveur de
la crémation
les arguments des crématistes sont
essentiellement sur le plan de
l'urbanisme plan de l'écologie mot très
à la mode maintenant et problèmes qui
sont posés aux collectivités aux villes
en particulier avec l'encombrement des
cimetières
mais les motivations de cette femme et
est un peu plus étonnantes
je suis claustrophobe alors rien qu'à
penser qu'un jour il faudrait que je
sois renfermé dans un monde irréel dans
un circuit d'abord et puis dans le
caveau avec une grosse pierre au dessus
de la tête
pour moi ça me ça me donnait des sueurs
froides en france c'est dans le nord
reste que les incinérations sont les
plus pratiquées en 2015 elle
représentait 80% des décès dans le
haut-rhin 66% en moselle et 65 %
haute-saône et c'était déjà le cas en
2001 sept professionnels du funéraire
expliquer pourquoi parce que nous sommes
proches de la suisse proche de
l'allemagne
et puis peut-être aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de
de protestants d'alsace qui pratiquaient
soit bien avant le catholique
si la crémation fait de plus en plus
d'adeptes dans l'hexagone les français
restent encore loin derrière les suisses
les tchèques ou les suédois qu'ils ont
tous adopté en grande majorité
[Musique]